[Musique]
cette vallée à cheval entre la France et
la Suisse c'est le pays de nemorinkai un
homme d'un autre temps il est né pile au
milieu du XIXe siècle au pissou un
village près de la rivière Doubs les
moringaille ne vous les rendre de compte
à personne il a vécu tout seul pendant
83 ans uniquement de la nature il y
avait pas de d'intermédiaires entre
entre le l'animal sauvage et
Énée Morin il faisait partie de
la sauvagerie du wildness comme des
Américains
un autre enfant du pissou Édouard Michel
qui a écrit en 1978 la biographie de
Némorin le livre est aujourd'hui épuisé
l'éditeur Philippe coberley a voulu
rééditer ce témoignage pour que l'on
n'oublie pas comment des hommes ont pu
vivre de la nature sans la détruire à
Villers-le-Lac le vieux loup du Saut du
Doubs admire lui aussi le choix de vie
de mémorin sa famille lui a toujours
parlé de cet homme d'après la grand-mère
bon c'est un grand gaillard
salut les belles c'est un personnage
inédit
à l'époque surtout à l'époque du pissau
c'était tout un peu décubénique comme on
dit à l'époque des royalistes et puis
lui il était anti un peu anti tout ça
tout le système
un personnage se mémorin jusqu'à sa mort
en 1933 il a vécu dans cette maison
perché au-dessus du doux le chasseur de
loutre est si célèbre que son prénom est
devenu un lieu-dit connu des randonneurs
du GR5
et là donc quand il revenait de la pêche
ou de la chasse il entrait par là
et puis là c'est là où il y a eu la
photo de sa mère
c'est émouvant d'être là presque un
siècle après Jacky Munier et sa famille
ont restauré la maison un havre de paix
sans électricité avec juste l'eau de la
source
filet de préparer ses hameçons de
remplir ces cartouches de poudre et de
plomb
quand on va dans la maison de quelqu'un
qu'il a imprégné comme ça toute sa vie
on a un peu l'impression qu'il est
toujours là
avec un balai créé en 1985 au Locle et
le groupe sang d'encre lui a dédié une
chanson
dans les années 50 le barrage du château
est construit pour produire de
l'électricité la rivière n'est plus
sauvage c'est un autre monde qui est en
marche
je veux de la nature mais il ne
l'abîmait pas il ne l'a détruisait pas
il mettait aucune espèce en péril et les
loutres c'est un bon exemple parce que
les les Suisses ont donné des primes
très importantes pour chaque peau de
l'autre mais les loups n'ont pas disparu
à cause de ça les loutres elles ont
disparu à cause des barrages à cause des
pesticides à cause de la pollution de
PCB
qu'on aimerait est mort il restait
encore des loutres
écrivain randonneurs enfants du pays
artiste tous ont été touchés par nemorin
des loutres et son choix radical vivre
en toute liberté